i  personally think  women use corn  for pleasure  men do also  but i think a lot of men use corners and  escape  okay to  live out their  fantasies because more time  men will watch corn and their category  of choice will be the polar opposite to  their misses mm-hmm  they'll never watch someone doesn't  trust them  and  men what we do is we tend to create a  fantasy in our own mind even if we're  chasing women we kind of like the chase  we like the story that we concocted our  mind and that's what men tend to do with  corn they always go for the crazy wild  things or the things that the things  that excite us most in life and in corn  are the things that we know we shouldn't  be doing